is there something you've learned about
yourself
about your deepest fears like you said
snakes
is there something that like if i were
to torture you i'm
so i'm russian so you know i always kind
of think
how can i murder these people then this
person that entered the room
but also how how could i torture you to
get some information out of you
what would i go with hmm it's
interesting you should say that i never
considered myself claustrophobic
but um because i don't mind small
environments
provided they're well ventilated
but i uh before covid i started going to
this russian banya
yeah um you know and then which i'm here
and i've never been to a ban yet so you
know the whole experience of
really really hot sauna yeah and the
what do they call it the plaza they're
hitting you with the leaves and yeah
and it gets really hot and humid in
there and there were a couple times
where
i thought okay this thing is below
ground it's
in a city where there are a lot of
earthquakes like if this
place crumbled and we were stuck in here
and i'd start getting a little panicky
and i realized i'm like i don't like
small confined spaces with poor
ventilation so i realize i think i have
some claustrophobia and i wasn't aware
of that before so i put myself into our
own
claustrophobia stimulus which involves
getting into an elevator
and with a bunch of people virtual
people and
the elevator gets stalled and at first
you're fine
you feel fine but then as we start
modulating the environment and we
actually can control
levels of oxygen in the environment if
we want to um
it is really uncomfortable for me and i
never would have thought you know i fly
i'm comfortable in planes i
but it is really uncomfortable and so i
think i've
unhatched a bit of a claustrophobia yeah
you